so I have six goats Ansel Adams's
because I'm a photographer so that
seemed fitting for my first two two
goats they are all mini goats but doctor
that's where I got next and he's a boor
goat and he was going to go in someone's
freezer he's a huge pain but then I have
Preston and Quincy they're twins and
they're probably the most lovable goats
I have and then we have Annie and Annie
is the star of the show and she's my
logo everyone loves her because she was
born at the farm so I think they feel
most bonded to her my name is Lanie
Morris and I'm the founder of Goat yoga
and this is my farm no regrets farm
farms give people that special feeling
like they're going back to the simple
days even when you drive up and you see
the old house and the old barn and it
just just like whoa this is cool so I'm
glad to share it last year
I ended up getting a divorce then in the
new year I was diagnosed with Sjogren's
Sjogren's is an autoimmune disease it's
basically where your immune system
starts attacking its own cells just
walking into work was really hard and
you know I get at my desk and just be
like oh I wonder if I'm gonna have to
collect disability soon you know because
I would just look forward every day to
coming home and the first thing I would
do is come out in the barn and go sit
out in the field and you know I walk out
there and all the goats follow behind me
and it just cracks me up when they're
all jumping around being crazy it's just
really hard to be depressed the hardest
thing about having a disease is getting
in your own head and if you get there
and you don't have any distractions you
can get in trouble and you know I live
alone and so I have a lot of time in my
head so that's what I needed I needed
about distraction it
kind of when I'm by myself with them
that it's the most therapeutic for me
but a friend asked me if I'd be
interested in offering a kid's birthday
party with the goats at the farm one of
the parents was a yoga instructor and
she's like we should totally have a yoga
class out here this is perfect and so we
started promoting it as goat yoga we
really thought just our friends and
family would show up because who does
this it was a sold-out class goats are
strolling around and it's just super
peaceful and so we took it from there
and started marketing goat yoga how
people are reacting is a huge part of my
therapy people from all over the United
States sent me the most amazing things
there's a quilt in the back of the barn
that I hung up and the lady sent me a
note and just said I've suffered from
depression my whole life and if this
makes anybody smile that'll make me
happy and that gives me chills I want
people to come out here and experience
this whether it be vets that just got
back from war or people with diseases or
just people that are sad you just have
to say the name and people smile because
it's so really the most special thing is
just watching their faces when a goat
comes towards them and they get to
snuggle they lose their minds
[Music]